over the last 30 years the Southern
Poverty Law Center has become a powerful
force in American politics there's a lot
of power and it gets it by
systematically slandering the political
enemies of the left oppose their agenda
and immigration practice conventional
Christianity believe in the biological
difference between the sexes host a show
like this one
and you can expect the SPLC to brand you
as an extremist a hate group an enemy of
humanity they've gotten rich doing it by
the way they've got an endowment of more
than 500 million dollars but even as it
called all of its political enemies evil
the SPLC was and you'll not be surprised
to hear this apparently operating on a
very different standard within their own
offices today the group abruptly
announced the firing of its founder
Morris Dees the group has not revealed
what exactly DS did its statement
implies behavior was severe and
widespread the SPL says that not only is
it fired these it will be bringing an
outside organization and to review the
work environment of the entire group
Josh Lewin who's a reporter in Alabama
who's reported on this cites an internal
SPLC email and says that DS was fired
for a mix of sexual harassment and again
buckle your seatbelt for this one racial
bias despite calling the group the
Southern Poverty Law stand there was
nothing impoverished at all about Morris
Dees his own lifestyle he lived very
well probably better than anyone else in
the state of Alabama he was 82
he was the SPL C's highest paid employee
and he lived in a luxurious place on a
couple of hundred acres he got rich by
frightening grandmother's sending him
direct mail and hurting his political
opponents that pays well this evening d
spoke with a local reporter and denied
all wrongdoing that's not surprising DS
has set himself up over 30 years as the
arbiter of good and bad he believes the
right thing so he is by definition a
good person you disagree with them and
you were by definition evil well
continue to follow the story because we
think it tells you a lot